we now know that there are no legally
valid or historically valid reasons to
prevent Donald Trump's former national
security adviser the non indicted one
john bolton from testifying in the
senate impeachment trial we suspect that
there are at least a couple of
republican votes in favor of john bolton
testifying we don't yet know whether
there will be 51 total votes republicans
are absolutely panicking that the
testimony that john bolton might give
could quote open the floodgates
according to Republican sources who
spoke to Axios yesterday I told you that
in John Bolton's upcoming book
he just says Trump personally told me
withhold the aid to Ukraine until
Ukraine smears Joe Biden publicly so
when you hear from different Trump
attorneys speculating that there was not
conditionality that there was not
pressure whatever and that there they
have no firsthand witnesses saying
otherwise john bolton would be such a
first-hand witness he would say
presumably if he tells the same story
that he tells in his book but the Trump
came to me and said hold the aid until
we get these investigation announcements
Republicans have said endlessly they
want first-hand sources but they are
working to block a first-hand source
like John Bolton so first and foremost
is the question of whether four
Republican senators will vote to bring
Bolton in to testify we dealt with that
in the last segment then there is part
two of this Axios is reporting that
Republican sources tell them party
leaders and the White House are going to
try to resist witnesses all together
including Bolton because as one aide put
it quote there is a sense in the Senate
that if one witness is allowed the
floodgates are open if Bolton says stuff
that implicates say make Mulvaney or
Mike Pompeo then calls for them to
testify will intensify as they should
that is exactly right what arguments
will Republicans make against the
testimony of Bolton when it comes up
there's gonna be a few things one we
already heard I played a clip earlier of
Senator John Barrasso
they will say you know we're doing a lot
here we've got 24 hours on one side 24
hours from the other side 16 hours of
questions we'll decide later do we
really need to hear more stuff in
general making the argument that just
looking at the clock like just the
number of hours that they've they've
done this would suggest they don't need
to hear from witnesses that's a fact
free assessment they will argue that
what Bolton has to say won't change the
primary facts now of course that's not
true John Bolton would be a firsthand
witnesses witness who would be able to
testify personally Trump told me
withhold the aid until they announced
the investigations they will say the aid
which was paused not withheld was
ultimately released and nobody ended up
publicly smearing Joe Biden now of
course that happened because they got
caught and they scrambled to clean it up
but Republicans will still use that as
an argument they will say the Ukrainian
president has said there was no pressure
on him to announce these investigations
and that the phone call didn't mention a
specific quid pro quo so we don't need
to hear from john bolton of course john
bolton would still be a first-hand
witness who could tell us exactly what
Trump said but that also ignores how
politics works right these things aren't
made explicit in phone calls between the
CEOs or the presidents it is all
discussed and pushed behind the scenes
by people like Rudy Giuliani and others
now of course every single one of those
talking points is easily debunk able and
it runs directly counter to the
Republican complaints about we run we
want firsthand witnesses and we don't
have them but they are still going to
make the strongest case possible to
prevent Bolton from testifying because
they know it would be a disaster so
let's hear from everybody under oath
let's hear from everybody in public and
then let's see whether the impending
Republican acquittal makes sense based
on the facts the degree of obstruction
that is taking place when it comes to
the impeachment trial is becoming a
bigger and bigger story I got emails
yesterday from a few of you saying
why won't Donald Trump testify shouldn't
Donald Trump have to testify in his own
impeachment trial no he shouldn't have
to that's not the law any good lawyer
would probably prevent their client
from testifying in equivalent
circumstances but does anybody think
Donald Trump could handle Underoath
testimony Donald Trump would be
uncontrollably lying within minutes if
not seconds and would perjure himself he
would likely reveal additional
wrongdoing that he's not even being
impeached for Hillary could handle it
remember she testified how many hours
was it dozens of hours for the Benghazi
fiasco Trump would implode in seconds
and that may actually be an interesting
narrative to try to goad Donald Trump
into testifying remind him Hillary did
it Hillary did it now the circumstances
are completely different but this is
Trump were talking about he wants to be
bigger and stronger and more powerful
and braver than Hillary maybe you could
actually get him to demand that his
lawyers let him testify unlikely final
note I don't think that if bolton
testifies Republicans vote to impeach
okay I've said this before I believe if
bolton testifies Republicans still vote
to acquit but it will be that much more
embarrassing and obvious that from the
get-go acquittal was a foregone
conclusion acquittal was what they
planned to do from the beginning they
will still acquit Donald Trump but the
Boulton testimony could stick in
people's minds john bolton publicly
testifying and saying donald trump
personally told me withhold the aid to
Ukraine until they announced the
investigations it could influence the
November election it might help to get
Donald Trump out if and when we go out
to vote in nine months
that's why it's important not because it
will get Republicans to vote to convict
the guy they're not going to do that
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show follow me at David Pakman I posted
one of the ugliest hate mails I've ever
received this morning on my Instagram
page at David Pakman check it out we'll
take a quick break and a lot more to
discuss today one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman